I guess the most commendable thing he's
done is,
uh,
not decide the bomb he ran or something.
Like,
I think I'm things he hasn't done that
it's commendable that he hasn't done
them,
but,
uh,
he can point to very little,
at least by my standards,
just commendable.
I mean,
he's retracted some of the more extreme,
uh,
Bush positions.
So for example,
say on Cuba,
uh,
Bush imposed condition,
the normal conditions are totally
outlandish and ridiculous,
which is why everyone except Israel
votes against them at the UN and why the
majority of Americans subject to them.
But the Bush went way beyond the and
post even harsher conditions and uh,
uh,
Obama with through some of those,
on,
uh,
nuclear issues,
he has indicated that the u s should
return to the main stream of
international affairs,
assign.
They consider again the Comprehensive
Test Ban Treaty move towards reducing
nuclear weapons.
Okay.
That's a step forward from bushes
position,
but it's a step towards the center and
towards the international main stream
and also towards the American public
opinion.
Uh,
and there's a number of other cases like
that where the,
the Bush administration,
especially its first term was quite
extreme,
which is why a,
the u s standing in the world fell to
historic lows.
Nothing much because I never expected
anything.
Um,
I th I was a little surprised by the
fact that he re-instituted uh,
some of the,
uh,
the,
judicial practices that
were kind of
unconscionable that Bush,
uh,
made use of,
like,
he wants preventative detention
permanently.
Uh,
uh,
he's been waffling about torture.
He's
refusing to grant a normal criminal
trials to people that they have no
evidence against a,
they claim to have none.
Uh,
things like that have been a little
surprising.
I don't think he had to be that extreme.
And,
uh,
in his,
interpretation of actually deviation
from any reasonable legal stuff.